vous l'avez sûrement déjà aperçu dans
votre commune depuis quelques semaines
une nouvelle agence de mobilité sillonne
les communes de 50 an en Yveline son nom
l'agence mobile le principe est simple
décentraliser l'agence de mobilité déjà
présente dans la gare de 50 ans en
Yveline à montinil le
Bretonneux l'idée évidemment est
d'apporter un service public
supplémentaire au plus près de nos
concitoyens et des habitants de
l'agglomération avec cette agence mobile
qui est donc derrière moi on a vu que la
demande en tout cas aussi pour la ation
et la réparation était était croissante
en revanche la petite difficulté qu'on
avait d'où cette innovation c'est
finalement nos services étaient
physiquement sur la gare de
Saint-Quentin en ieline Montin
Bretonneux et donc pour des communes un
peu plus éloignées de la ville nouvelle
et du cœur urbain je pense notamment à
manilé à Villepreux à coignère on s'est
dit que c'était cohérent d'apporter le
service au plus près de la demande donc
c'est l'ambition qu'on a avec cette
agence mobile avec cette agence
itinérante vous pourrez notamment
récupérer ou rendre un Vél loué faire
entretenir votre vélo personnel acheter
ou recharger vos titres de transport ou
encore vous informer à propos des
déplacements en transport en commun un
service de proximité très attendu par
les adeptes du vélo et par les usagers
des transports en commun aujourd'hui les
Plaisirois sont sont Avid sont en
attente vraiment de tout ce qui est voie
voie verte euh
c'est-à-dire le développement du vélo
l'agence est présente dans les
différents points de passage des
communes de 50 an en Yveline vous pouvez
retrouver le calendrier de ces tournées
sur le site Île-de-France
mobilité